All right, let's hear it.
Let's hear it, Mary.
I'd offer you a snack,
but you already are one.
Hey, I'm Peyton.
I'm Mary.
And I'm Xolo,
and we are the cast of Cobra Kai.
In the series,
both of us date Miguel.
And today, we're going to see
who the most charming is, IRL.
And I'll be the judge.
This is "Charm Battle."
Do you know karate?
'Cause your body is kicking.
I think...
I'll give that one a five.
Are you kidding?
Peyton's like,
"Are you shitting me,
I would never say this!"
Are you a time traveler?
Because I see you in my future.
Okay.
The voice makes
me a little uncomfortable,
it's a little unsettling.
That was charming.
I'll give that one a seven.
Oh, shoot.
Didn't we have class together?
'Cause I could've sworn
we had chemistry.
I feel like that one was,
more endearing than anything.
I'll give you a seven as well,
that one was better than
the first one, for sure.
If you mess up, it
gets points from Xolo.
Exactly yeah, there we go.
In that case, (mumbles)
(mumbles)
I'd invite you swimming but,
I'm already drowning
in your eyes.
That one was a little too corny.
I'm gonna have to give that
one like a four or a five.
Whatever, fine. I'll take it.
In my eyes, that was great.
Aww, we just end
up with each other,
that's how this
"Charm Battle" goes.
You have amazing legs,
is it because you've been
running through my head all day?
Wait I, wait,
Wait, repeat it,
I think I misheard it,
what did you just say?
I said, "You have amazing legs,
is it because you've been running
through my head all day?"
Okay, okay.
I like that one actually,
I think that's the
best one so far,
I think that's
a nine, for sure.
Whoa!
- Yeah.
- That's a good one.
- But I think, but I think Mary's--
- I think he's just insecure
'cause he doesn't do leg
day at the gym, so...
Yeah, exactly.
I think I just needed
- that little pick me up.
- Doesn't matter now,
we can't see your legs.
Exactly.
All right, let's let's
hear it Peyton,
err, let's hear it Mary.
You called me some
other ho's name,
how dare you?
I was about to say...
Have I seen you
at the dojo?
I just feel like you
and I would work out.
Okay that one,
I like that one actually,
that one was cool,
it wasn't where I
thought it was gonna go.
I think that one is a 10.
Xolo, the way you're
judging these, is hilarious.
Was your dad a fighter?
'Cause you're a knockout.
I liked that one.
I felt like the delivery
was really, really good.
Like I think that's
a 10 as well.
A 10?
Did you hear Peyton,
the joy in her voice,
"A 10?"
"Oh my God!"
Finally.
This is my last shot
at redemption.
All right, let's hear it,
let's hear it Mary.
I'd offer you a snack,
but you already are one.
Okay, I, that,
okay, that just makes
me uncomfortable,
I think...
Your face is flushed,
I feel like that gets
me bonus points.
I think, yeah, I was
not expecting that one,
I think that one was a nine
that one was good.
Do you have a name, or
can I call you mine?
Are you Netflix?
'Cause I could
watch you for hours.
Even if earth didn't have
gravity, I'd still fall for you.
Those are all very good.
Actually, all of those
were really good.
I think it's that's like a 12 or 13.
Redemption.
All right, let's see it Mary.
Come on Mary.
You're like a
sister to me Mary,
it's okay, you got this.
Oh, savage.
Hey, my name is Mary,
but you can call me
tonight or tomorrow.
If you were words on a
page, you'd be fine print.
Can I walk you home?
'Cause my parents always
told me to follow my dreams.
Okay, I felt like you
started off very strong.
The first one was--
Yeah, yeah, yeah,
that was the plan.
It was like, start out strong
so you didn't get
overwhelmed at the end.
Exactly, there we go,
I think it's an 11 for me,
I think Peyton just
had the swag,
whereas you had
the good delivery.
I mean, that's fair.
Don't say it like that.
Well, I'm waiting to
hear the final score,
and we'll decide
how mad I am.
Okay.
Oh, what!
I knew it!
Oh damn!
I really thought
Mary was gonna win.
She's gone.
Okay, this is--
You gave us all even
scores up to the end.
I think I got a 13, that
brought me up a little bit.
Hey, well this is a very
La La Land moment here,
I was not anticipating this.
I'm sorry, Mary.
Guys, thank you so
much for watching.
Be sure to like,
comment and subscribe
to catch more
content like this.
And don't miss Cobra Kai.
On Netflix.